one of the things we talk about is the
best spider-man stories are when Peter
and spider-man's worlds collide
it's been a thrill working on spider-man
for the first time and doing it with our
longtime partners at Playstation their
Sony interactive entertainment
spider-man is a character that is super
beloved by many people and Omni Act
myself included and we also know that he
has millions of fans around the world
it's one of the most beloved characters
of all of media period so we felt a lot
of responsibility to try and make a
great experience for players and
but focus really hard on bringing you a
kind of a fresh spider-man experience
that respects the DNA of the series and
feels right but also will surprise you
in new ways and it starts with the fact
that this is not an origin story this is
not based on a comic current movie it's
a brand new experience starting a
23-year old Peter Parker who is
masterful at fighting crime and
it's gonna have some great personal
relationships you're gonna see the
Peters side of it and you're also going
to see the spider-man side so I don't
think it was really hard to decide that
we wanted to you know take the best
things and our favorite things from past
spider-man comics and lore there's so
much good stuff over you know decades
you have all these great characters and
spider-man has been in so many different
situations and bought so many villains
and fans have many favorite moments and
so we wanted to honor that legacy and
try and do things that we as fans would
want to see while also providing a lot
of Easter eggs for fans as well but we
weren't just thinking it had to be all
classic I mean if you look at the choice
of mr. negatives he's a very modern
spider-man villain Dan Slott created him
I think nine years ago maybe 10 now so
he's relatively newcomer and if you
haven't been keeping up with the comics
you may have no idea who he is so it's
great to bring him to potentially his
largest audience yet it was really
important to us to you know tell a story
that we wanted to tell we have amazing
ideas we love spider-man and his fans if
we were gonna sit down and play like a
new
big spider-man game we would want
something that would you know feel like
very much like spider-man but at the
same time be surprising and so it was
kind of just us knowing that if we were
gonna play this game it's what we would
want
creating a 23 year old Peter Parker
allowed us a lot of things that we
couldn't have gotten with a 15 year old
one firstly he's already great at
fighting crimes so we can let players be
awesome at being spider-man this isn't a
game where he's trying to learn his
powers and figure out how to web-swing
and not being good at fighting guys we
can throw you right into the deep end
into some crazy situations because you
are a masterful spider-man who's been
spider-man for eight years on top of
that there's sort of high school
relationships that you have that the
classic 15 year old Peter Parker
explores we wanted to sort of explore
what those relationships what your
relationships are and what your life is
like after you get out of university and
you start a job while also trying to be
a superhero
it's a classic thing about spider-man is
how to handle a next step of life and
that's something that Peter always has
dealt with whether he's been in high
school or he's in college we're just
doing that for what it's like when you
finally are an adult well New York is
this like melting pot of cultures so we
wanted to reflect that as accurately as
we could and there's kind of a very
large Chinatown district one of these
characters to still be very authentic to
who they were like just because our
Peter Parker is 23 years old he still
should act and feel like Peter Parker
and maybe people are wearing are in
different jobs like MJ is a reporter at
The Daily Bugle or Norman Osborn as the
mayor but we still want them to be true
to their actual characters and true to
the character traits that have been
defined for them so that's kind of how
we're blending things and and I think
showing other cultures especially as it
relates to kingpin or to the city of New
York or to mr. negative is just
important to be authentic to their to
those characters and that universe so we
have Marvel's New York the island of
Manhattan after the first mission you
can just swing around and see the whole
swing everywhere all the way from
financial district up to Harlem we
wanted to have a really detailed city
that feels doesn't just look like New
York but feels like it when you're in it
this is not a dark abandoned city it's
got you know pedestrians and traffic so
as you explore the city there will be
additional activities for you to do some
of these are little collectibles like
Peter leaves backpacks everywhere when
he goes to fight crimes and then he
forgets where they are each one has like
a different piece of memorabilia so to
speak that kind of tells you a little
bit about the story of his first eight
years of spider-man there's other
collectibles too like there's landmarks
that Peter can take photos of there are
stakeouts that black cat has been up to
but then there's also side quests and
some interesting side missions a big
game and it will depend a lot on how
much site content you do but even if you
don't do a lot of the side content
there's still a very satisfying and long
story there for him but one that I
really think is interesting and we tried
to make Tye story and everything where
we could is there are these research
stations that Harry Osborn set up as a
project to help clean up New York now
Harry is currently away he parries
Peters best friend he's currently away
in Europe pepper studying in school and
so he asked Peter to check in on his
research stations for him but little
does Harry know that actually spider-man
is doing the checking in and using some
special web powers to help
do the research that Harry was trying to
get done we're huge fans of spider-man
and insomniac so we've been working hard
on this for over three and a half years
we poured a lot of energy and effort
into it we're very excited for you all
to play the game try to avoid spoilers
did a lot of little surprises and big
surprise is still left to be discovered
and we can't wait for you all to play it
on September 7